and then with jack
like your guy's a story finding jack
because you know if you saw jack harlow
uh when you guys first signed him you
know he doesn't scream like superstar
he looks like napoleon doesn't look like
yeah he looks like like like someone who
works at the geek squad at best buy or
something you know what i mean
and he's from louisville which is like a
place that's not known as like a talent
hub
right yeah i mean dram pretty much
really kind of steered that in the
direction but
again when we all met it's something
that the guys have
in their eye and they the way they
carried itself is like bro
that's gonna be some work but it's gonna
work you know what i mean and that's
we all see it we're like man we gotta do
that one we got to it don't matter what
he looked like it just
it's the feeling it was the energy that
he had he already had a squad with him
his producer was dope his producer still
is dope as hell
two for one you know i just was like it
just was there and it was like
let's do it you know i was in it didn't
take too much
and it's hard to get these guys to agree
like so it's three of us right and it's
supposed to be two out of three but
really i'm usually just the guy that's
waiting to say yes right right
i bring a lot of stuff to the table and
it's hard as hell to really convince
this guy
and as hard as hell to convince him too
you know what i mean so a lot of stuff
that comes to the table especially from
our anr staff like it's a lot of stuff
that's shot down so
when we see something that we like like
we really attached i can imagine like um
the like the success of what's popping
had to really
like it had to be sweeter than
a lot of stuff you guys have done before
his generation now
because i feel like at that time people
were kind of like well you know with the
oozy [ __ ] being out there
and then you know jack harlow comes
what was i mean is it triple platinum uh
yeah like that and the craziest part
about that record was i remember when
we played it in the music meeting and i
love i'd already heard it on spotify and
i'd love the record but it doesn't it
didn't have like it wasn't like a
traditionally formatted song
like when you first heard it you're like
wait i gotta figure out where the hook
is type [ __ ]
but how like sweet was that like it
almost was like a
i felt like if i was y'all i would have
been like yeah [ __ ] we did it
again
we did at some point but we also like us
not staying in the public and doing too
much cheddar chatter made it even more
sweet
absolutely you know never really came
out and did yeah it was just fun
let's keep working man just make some
[ __ ] yeah we still had the fun in it
you know what i mean to make it even
better we have been working with jack
and he's been making certain type of
songs
and we always say to him all three of us
yo you can rap
but they always like yeah i know but i
wanna i got this vibe i be like you can
rap right
you know what i'm saying so when that
came out it was like bro
your first big record you got rapping
you see what i'm saying and he started
out like that dark knight was a rap
record and
we just always stuck with that you know
what i mean so
that's what makes it sweeter that we
just put our head down and just kept
working
and it just popped up it wasn't like oh
we gotta hit y'all we ready it was just
like man we
rock and roll and again and i don't know
i i
you know sometimes i feel like you know
we've
maneuvered through our careers i don't
necessarily want to say
underdogs but feeling like yo like
this is what we do like we've been doing
this a long time we got to show you
again this is what we do
so i was like you know even through that
it was like again us not really
being vocal about it and just working
and you know having the results we have
it's like
you know like come on guys like duh
we've been telling you this for years
this is what we do right
right we're gonna keep doing it you know
what i'm saying so yeah i mean it
obviously it was definitely like it was
it was a sweet feeling you know what i'm
saying to
you know to come out through the year of
2020 and you know
have such a productive you know moment
for generation now